right welcome to this meeting of cabinet
and we start with apologies from for
absence please Caroline yes chairman
apologize receive from councillor house
and councillor Pemberton ok discloses
listed in Phnom good so before we get on
to the minutes I'll just like to say
that as far as the Chairman's statement
girls there's a slight change to the
terms of reference of the member
development working group in that the
original warm said governance and
democracy portfolio holder would be
chairman to further portfolio holders
the to further portfolio holders has now
changed to one portfolio holder all the
other conditions remain save so minutes
confirm and signed the minutes of the
meeting is everyone happy with the
minutes grade good thank you
so moving on in the absence of Darren
Pemberton I will take the Eddington I'm
full ready neighborhood plan and those
of you with eagle eyes who actually read
it will say that on page eight in an
error it refers to ship stone on stellar
neighborhood development plan not
Edgington and fall ready neighborhood
plan so our apologies so that that would
apologies the Weddington enough already
I should just point out that at this
stage the council has no discretion
decision statement will be published
after this and given that we have no
discretion and that the attention enough
already Neighborhood Development Plan
was endorsed by more than the required
threshold in the referendum of the 11th
of October can we recommend to council
on page 7 that the Edington handful
ready neighborhood development plan
appendix warm is adopted with immediate
effect with the consequence that it
becomes a part of the development plan
for stratford-on-avon district all those
in favor grade thank you and our
congratulations to eat eaten and fall
ready for their completion of the
neighborhood development plan next item
on the agenda again in the absence of
Darrin I will take the wels born and
Walton neighborhood plan and fortunately
this does actually say well was born and
Walton it is exactly the same as before
again the council have no option but to
grant this so the recommendation is that
the wels born and Walton Neighborhood
Development Plan appendix one is adopted
with immediate effect with the
consequence that it becomes part of the
development plan for stratford-on-avon
district everyone in agreement great and
once again our congratulations to well
was born and Walton completing their
neighborhood development plan so moving
on item 6 is treasury management
strategy mid-year mid-year review
2018-19
and organ thank you chairman this
reviews the strategy that was approved
in February 2018 and updates the
position in the light of the prevailing
economic conditions the council employs
the services of capita asset services
who advise on treasury management and
investment matters and economic update
has provided in Para two of the report
along with an interest rate
to forecast the council's priority is to
ensure security of capital and liquidity
and to obtain an appropriate level of
return that is consistent with the
council's risk appetite the approved
limits within the annual investment
strategy have not been breached during
the first six months and the investment
counterparty criteria selection approved
by the treasury management strategy is
meeting the requirements of the treasury
management function the council
currently has no external borrowing or
debt nor is there an expectation that
borrowing will be undertaking and taken
during this financial year the
recommendation to Council is to note the
report including the Treasury activity
detailed in five one two five four in
addition to this sip fir have issued
revised codes requiring all councils to
prepare a capital strategy to provide an
overview of how capital expenditure
financing and treasury management
contribute towards the provision of
services how associated risk is managed
and the implications for future
financial sustainability a report
setting out the council's capital
strategy will be presented to Council
before the end of March 2019 thank you
you can logon any points that people
wish to raise councillor kettle how long
have we used them for and should we do
we ever consider an alternative advisor
on these matters because capita is a
very well-known organisation I accept
but it might be interesting to see
whether other people might be able to
provide services for counter orgin do
you wish to respond thank you the the
treasury management and
vestment advice is tendered every seven
years capture are actually they change
their name they're now called link but
so it is tendered every seven years for
the best service that we can get the
capital framework there's two main place
Thank You mr. Buckland just one
interesting statement in the paper on
page eighteen although it applies to the
eurozone it says the horizon is less
clear than it seemed just a short while
ago I think that would apply in general
across the world economy and I think it
is just something to actually bear in
mind as we go forward with that we in
agreement with the recommendation to
Council to note the report great thank
you everyone so moving on we now come to
the adoption of personal data breach and
incident management policy which is down
as deputy leader but is of course
councilor Thank You general this report
forms part of the work we are required
to undertake to satisfy our
responsibilities under the general data
protection regulation and the Data
Protection Act at 2018 as a council is a
data controller it must have in place a
plan to detect investigate and contain
and report any breach this policy will
form part of the council's information
governance framework accordingly I asked
cabinet to approve the recommendations
of this
on page 25 mainly that one that the
personal data protection and incident
management policy is approved and it
comes into operation with immediate
effect secondly that the information
governance manager is authorized in
consultation with a relevant portfolio
holder to make any subsequent changes to
the personal data protection and
incident management policy the data
protection policy and the data retention
policy and thirdly that the head of ICT
and revenues is authorized in constant
consultation with a relevant portfolio
holder to make any subsequent changes to
the ICT Kilda practice if we agree this
journalist can then go forward to the
next full council for adoption thank you
Thank You counselor so will we all happy
with the recommendations on page 25
Thank You counselor will that's agreed
now we can actually move on to the
deputy leader for the strategic
investment case local housing company
councillor Cargill thank you very deeply
okay and it was in September 17th at the
affordable housing working group agreed
a report be commissioned to provide a
business case so well the local housing
company to be carry on forward
it was commissioned earlier this year
and we have just received the report I
have commented a number of times on the
lack of progress and on this proposed
production when it finally arrived it
only focused on the structure of the
local housing company which we asked for
but the investment strategy for this
particular care home for the production
council in this local housing company
I'm not sure why but GVA any focused on
one investment model the buy-to-let
market as members of the group will
remember that was only one small part of
the company's strategy considered
however not element at the report and
demonstrates that given the high house
prices in this district and the expected
or income especially from affordable
housing tenants a simple investment
model by this council would not produce
a viable return and therefore could put
the council's investment at risk that
will not come as a surprise
I'm sure to anyone I can't accept that
risk and therefore proposal we accept
the recommendations in this paper that
say a local housing company is not
established on the basis the vital it's
funded entirely through borrowing and
that a further review of his objectives
are undertaken in relation to the local
housing markets including an appraisal
of alternative delivery models as
identified in one to two of the repor I
am happy with the recommendations on the
structure of the company that's enclosed
in this report because it does give us a
reasonable working model for a company
local housing company in the government
arena local government arena
needless to say there areas of to be
looking at but I embedded to the working
group can do though okay this should to
say also this administration personally
are committed to the local housing
company fully expect like given a
different investment models reasonable
rates of return can be achieved too that
we have agreed as I mentioned to set up
the or re-establish the affordable
housing working group with the modified
terms of reference if required to
quickly come up with better defined
terms
costas to learn something let me leave
that to one side chairman because I'm
sure somebody will come back for the
figures of what it's cost us but when we
first looked at this we are getting
considerable amounts of money in section
106 agreements from developers for off
site contributions to we take money in
exchange for millions in section 106
agreements where developers have
undertaken to pay as money for
affordable housing chairman I hope we
can include in the remit of the
recommendations that we should
investigate ways in which this council
can use that money and clearly there's a
legal question to start with can we use
that money but if we can German I feel I
just looked at the latest accounts of
orbit they have 23 directors or stomach
paid over a hundred thousand a year
chairman orbit is a commercial
enterprise these days social enterprise
in this council if possible developing
houses on land that we already own and
then this council would have a revenue
stream a guaranteed revenue stream
because I contention if you've got the
land for free if the developers are
paying for building the houses you will
then make a profit and I would like to
see an investigation as to whether this
is possible thank you John
I agree thank you
as the chairman of OSC there was quite a
considerable amount of debate including
with councillor Morse on this particular
issue
I too am concerned that we do keep
asking GVA
to produce you
reports for us and I'm also concerned
that we're paying the money I don't
think this one is actually worth the
paper it's written on and would quite
like it back because I would have done
it for free cancel it it's really
depressing because this is a very very
very important thing to us as a council
and I know how to list and so I do beg
you to push on with this as a number one
priority in terms particularly of us
needing to find more ways of self
financing as the years go on and to be
much more creative the other point is
that if you if we insist on using GV a
are they able to be creative or is there
somebody else we could get these kind of
reports from I also notice it was April
it was commissioned thank you
well what can I say 29 pages in this
report I just wonder how many thousands
of pounds per page it costs us I'm not
convinced it's got value for money
I think I've said this before I said it
again it's a one-dimensional report it's
not very thorough at very exploratory I
do remind members that it was a portable
housing working group they actually
commissioned this report so we knew
there would be a cost involved in there
whether it's good value for money well
there we go I personally and I can't
speak out of turn on this particular one
but we'd have to look at which company
would use for future reports in this
particular area in the future Thank You
councillor Cargill if I could just
comment on one of the things council
Moore said I have to say that the GVA
evaluation was based on open market
housing prices and rental levels not
affordable
their results will be even worse if it
was affordable one of the other things
that actually came out very very clearly
the work that's being done is the issue
of if we have a hundred percent wholly
owned housing company then the accounts
have to be fully consolidated into the
council accounts oh that brings in a
serious element of risk and that were
they Housing Company to actually lose
money or were the housing company to
invest in houses and the price of houses
fall then any write offs incurred by the
housing company would actually then feed
straight through into the council's
accounts if my understanding is from mr.
Buckland that if that happened and it
drove our reserves below the level of
reserves we have to maintain which
carries about two and a half million
that would mean we would actually have
to take action to make sure that the
reserves remained at or above the
minimum level in other words if
something went wrong not that we would
plan for anything to go wrong it could
have an impact direct impact on council
services I think our view as a cabinet
is that if we can come up with a model
that works and delivers financial
returns fine were taking a risk with the
fundamental business of the council
which he been a council is a problem and
that was one of the reasons why I made
the point I made in the earlier paper
about the uncertainty in the economy
rest assured we will carry out a further
review of the objectives and I have to
say many of the cabinet members are
committed to try and find in a way of
their Kinney local housing company
actually work counselor kettle
I completely agree with everything you
just said in terms of the rest of the to
the district council if we have a wholly
owned subsidiary but as a council we
have acknowledged that we have a major
problem with affordable housing in this
district and that is why we set the
route of looking at affordable pricing
being delivered through some mechanism
surrogates District Council and I note
paragraph 1.2 of the GBA report that
they are commissioned to help establish
a housing delivery company that was
presumably with what their little
engagement identified and yet more what
we now have the report is that they were
doing yes we have to minimize the risk
to this council and on repairs quite
rightly but there must be a mechanism
and if GVA have not got the experience
or the knowledge in which ways to
identify one then we need to find an
alternative advisor who will prefer to
stick their neck on mine and say we
believe this is the right mechanism to
go forward there are many many ways of
dealing with this and the answer of
advising us that we shouldn't be doing
it is not actually what we should be
doing and I believe and I think we need
to look very carefully GBA have not
delivered what paragraph 1 by 2 the
reporter said and therefore we need to
find somebody either either they go back
and rewrite the support in line with our
expectations and we have their client or
we find somebody who is prepared to help
us and establish a mechanism it may be
complicated it may have a number of
different issues and that's because the
moss is quite the rightly said we need
to consider very carefully the economics
and how it works but at the end of the
day we have an ability here to deliver
housing for those who can't afford
market rates if we get it right so
completely in conflict with that let me
go utilize I suggest the term we are
going to do better if they can't we go
that's wearing ask for our fees back
I I think counsel the cattle your
dissatisfaction is shared widely the
where we are proposing to take this
forward is to actually set up him and
the working group I've already
approached people about being on that
member working group and it needs to be
set up very quickly to take this issue
forward and see if there is a viable way
of establishing a housing company that
will actually provide affordable housing
for the district so that is what we are
proposing to do and the recommendations
on page 45 cover that and the paragraph
is not 122 it's 123 and recommendation 2
is that the further review of its
objectives is undertaken in relation to
the local housing markets including an
appraisal of alternative delivery models
as identified in paragraph 123 of the
report and that I think is where the
work will be done as is said in the
report there is a strong political
commitment to find a way through this so
with that can I have your agreement to
the recommendations on page 45 please
great thank you
nine which is motorcycle parking on on
waterside and this is councilor organ
thank you chairman the Bancroft Gardens
includes the paved area of the old
waterside which is adjacent to the road
named waterside so we must remember to
keep the clear distinction between the
paved area and the road we're talking
about the paved area which is within the
Bancroft Gardens the bylaws covering the
Bancroft gardens were established in
1905 and they are still valid if
somewhat out-of-date they do not permit
vehicles at the Bancroft gardens so for
example they would not commit that
permit mobility scooters because these
are classed as vehicles
I'm sure also the man that goes round
with the vehicle to empty the litter
bins would also not be permitted
so these bylaws are somewhat in need of
a review so if nothing else this has
brought it to the fore that it's time to
actually look at these the motorcycles
have historically parked at Waterside
but following the repaving of the area
in 2009 an enforcement contract was put
into place to prevent motorcycle parking
this contract has lapsed resulting in
gatherings of motorcycles on Wednesday
evenings many people like to promenade
to see the motorcycles however there has
been an official complaint that it
should not be allowed and hence why we
are discussing it here along with the
bylaws the the inadequacies of the
bylaws can only be addressed by council
not by cabinet
however cabinet are permitted to express
a view as to whether they would like to
permit the future motorcycle gatherings
on waterside and that is what we're here
to do today q councilor organ and I
believe we have members of the public
who wish you to speak on these and that
ease
chicken McCullough if you will come
forward and please use a microphone and
can I just say that you have three
minutes thank you and thank you
everybody forgiveness that a little time
to talk to you I have provided a book
presenter the story of what goes on down
there and really without going outside
of that today I think the only thing I
would say is that everything is in this
true and honest little book here what
goes on down there we've been called
lots of things they say we fight with
the services men and I say this and that
it isn't true of course is there's a
nice photograph there of a shaking hands
with the big man who came and apologized
and said look we don't know anything
about this report that's gone on but
anyway I think it also circles around
we're trying to keep a tradition going
motorbikes have been here since 1928
it's a big scrambling clever letting -
there was a lovely group started here
called the Shakespeare MCC and they did
everything very very professionally they
made badges up relating to all the
Shakespeare plays it was all done really
nice like we're trying to do today and
we're trying to keep that going that's
40 years let's concentrate on the local
group since 1976 as an article there in
the Birmingham Mail from 76 and the
meetings have gone on with without
incident or accident I think we'd all
say all accidents result from speed
anyway and there's no speed involved
down there we try our best we've got the
posters telling the bikers what they
must do and following it not to glowing
report in The Herald somebody a scare
monger really said this was happening
and that was happening so we wrote to
the hell they were still come to come on
down let me see what we do and this has
been put together a little bit quickly
but they said look these are very very
charitable people down there raising
thousands of pounds for charity
due to our meetings and they wrote back
it says lovely friendly meeting we'd
love to come and see you all again
and that's what the meeting involves
down on waterside every Wednesday
just so friendly people don't think yeah
the 76 article in the Birmingham mail
with the local group starting it could
have been us writing it really it said
we select our members very carefully
we're out to prove that motorcycle
riders are not already Cowboys and we
feel that an organization like ours will
help foster a responsible attitude
towards motorcyclists amongst
motorcyclists and I'm also just like to
say I'm very passionate about Stratford
myself I'll do all the heritage tours
I've done mr. Shakespeare's walk down to
London and all of it so um we do look
after the place and I'll put a page on
there looking after waterside there's
also two pages one from Stratford forum
one from shut for forum again where they
did a straw poll and I just said 30 cent
mr. girl mr. McComb all right the straw
poll said focus on waterside for or
against 580 people wanted to comment and
said 97 percent said yes
the other three didn't actually say no
there was some don't knows in amongst it
and then the other is a forward and
where somebody went on and said do you
want them and they all say yes we want
the motor box back here been here for a
long time I think that's about it to
1905 but I can go back to 1964 when I
was 16 years old of the Triumph Tiger
Club 200cc and we used to chase the mods
down waterside and park on the water so
now it's come round to our mobility
scooter I'm afraid
[Laughter]
so I mean armful one who supports a
motorcyclist on water side there are
nice people they boost the local economy
they look after the motor pipes it's
it's a picture of down there sometime
and we should be very proud of these
more senior citizens looking after their
motorcycles so I for one support it but
I would like to see the bylaws updated
to protect obviously thank you sir all
good yes I think if it is the view of
cabinet to put a view to Council in
favor of permitting the motor bikes to
continue to gather at Waterside then it
might be that that would be couched such
that it was not just ad hoc but
organised gatherings and a license
something along those kind of lines the
council organ councilor francelli do you
wish to speak yeah it's in my district
Ward so I have been asked to comment on
it which I have done I decide to expand
on that because I have spoken to and
nobody has contacted me with a negative
but people I've actually spoken to come
up to me in the street some have
expressed some concern and surprised
that the motorcycles might be excluded
from the foot from waterside I have had
quite a lot of support caddy acted in a
way that counsel was just said providing
there is sufficient space left providing
that if too many people turn up for the
space there are some there are some way
of actually organizing that and if there
is a serious spillage of some sort or
damage there is some way of actually
looking after that responsible club
organization in place with whom those
arrangement could be made could I just
say on a personal level my mother when
she was restricted to a wheelchair
living in the Bancroft she'd be in a
motorcycle
and one of the greatest pleasures that
she had was to be pushed on there to
actually meet up with the guys I've
actually talked motorcycles so I've got
a personal sort of response to it so I
hope we can find a way Thank You
councillor French Li I have to say that
everyone who spoken to me about the
issue has been very supportive of the
motorcycles on the bancroft so I think
with that if we actually look at the
recommendation it says an option
identified in Section 2 well section 2
says the options to the cabinet in
relation to this matter are limited to
help inform the council of a review of
bylaws the cabinet are permitted to
express a view as to whether they would
like to permit the future motorcycle
gathering on water side from the
comments that we have heard I would
assume that the council are very much
mining to permit future motorcycle
gatherings on the water side assuming
that they are organised and that to me
would seem sorry an excellent suggestion
councillor brain we will do that and
make sure that is captured in the
minutes given what we have said I think
that means that we wish to if I might
just help I think it would be rather
constraining the council to put in some
conditions at this stage about their job
which is to review the bylaws there are
model viable laws in place but I prefer
it if the
expression was just confined to the
support for that or not for motorcycles
in that area advice is always welcome
mr. Grafton presumably then this means
that given the discussion we've had in
cabinet we are expressing a view about
the future of motorcycle gatherings on
waterside and the implications of that
is that the council should review the
bylaws is that appropriate to say yes to
fold yes good thank you
is everyone counseling the point that I
was making was it's not really the right
stage to put those caveats in to what
I'm sure the council which everybody I
think it's chairman with the council
councillor kettle you can make sure that
happens okay is everyone happy with that
conclusion
agreed thank you page 91 local
environmental enforce local
Environmental Quality enforcement policy
counselor brain chairman leader this
report represents a proposal for the
council to develop a local environmental
quality enforcement policy for formal
adoption across stratford-on-avon
district you will see that the policy
set out in Appendix 1 pages 1 to 5
you will know that the council is a
statutory waste collection authority and
statutory literal poverty the council is
committed to enhancing the
attractiveness of the district and
reducing anti-social behaviour crime and
fear of crime these commitments
recognize a link between poor local
environmental quality leq the perception
of place and the fear of crime these
these commitments also recognize that
everyone in the district has a personal
responsibility to manage the base
responsible responsibly and keep the
district free of litter flight is
another leq issues DG graffiti the
policy set say to the council will use
the powers and tools at its disposal to
ensure that enforcement work is carried
out in an effective consistent
proportionate and fair manner across the
district the scope of this policy
extends to all leq issues experienced
across the district on public land the
enforcement work the council will take
actions to support residents businesses
and visitors while raising awareness of
good practice in terms of waste
management litter control and other ally
q issues the level of the enforcement
action taken will take into account the
risk the impact and severity of the
offense and the intent of the offender
the use of the use of proportionate
enforcement and act as an effective
deterrent to repeat offending and how to
deter others from committing offenses
which cause damage to local
environmental quality under no
circumstances will the council use fixed
penalty notices as a means to generate
income whether it's sufficient evidence
and the Public Interest test is met the
council will normally prosecute chairman
the benefits of the council formally
adopt any leq enforcement policy
as follows it would enhance the
attractiveness of the district by
reducing incidence of environmental
crime and anti-social behavior it would
raise awareness of good practice in
terms of waste management litter control
and other
leq issues it would ensure the
enforcement work is coming at an
effective consistent proportional manner
across the district chairman the
recommendation is on page 91 although
you have three options but I would steer
the cabinet to go with the
recommendation on paragraph two of the
report Thank You councillor brain
Chancellor Cargill just a comment really
I just like to say that I think that our
street scene Department a a very very
good we have very sort of a clean
district and they're held actually in
high regard even by the county which is
was a bit of a surprise to us so I think
they are doing an excellent job well I
think this will only help with the areas
which was
[Music]
from the contract yes counselor brains
advices craves that until it's adopted
public highway we haven't really got a
any authority to be on there cleansing
and that would be the duty of the
developer who's brought forward the side
walk this report would allow you to do
if you chose to adopt this policy is if
any of the offenses were committed on
that land we could take action against
the perpetrator of those events with a
fixed penalty notice so whilst it
wouldn't solve the problem it might give
some assistance the policy would only
allow us to serve expenditures on the
person who actually generated the
literature or the fly-tipping so it
would be in your example the school kid
dropping the kick okay another window
but we probably wouldn't use the
enforcement in that instance
okay I think that indicates there is a
limited amount we can do about the issue
you've raised counselor kettle
nevertheless the recommendation on page
91 that the local environment quality
enforcement policies formally adopted in
line with the corporate strategy
statutory obligations national guidance
and principles of good enforcement do I
have your agreement to that
recommendation good thank you
move on to the severe weather emergency
protocol the council has been operating
a severe weather protocol since December
2011 this protocol was designed to
ensure that steps were taken to provide
all known rough sleepers with the
opportunity of shelter during severe
cold weather we have no dedicated
emergency commendation for use for when
the protocol is triggered it is
bed-and-breakfast accommodation which is
used for those risk of sleepers who
accept the offer of accommodation in
addition to this cold weather protection
the council provides of the support for
the rough sleepers all year round and
this is described in paragraph 1.4 of
the report the protocol takes account of
national guidance which did advise that
the trigger should be a forecast of a
nighttime temperature of zero or below
for three consecutive nights I'd like
you to draw to your attention that the
National guidance has since changed and
it's now suggested that the severe
weather protocols should also include a
trigger as soon as there is a forecast
over zero degrees or below irrespective
of the number of nights recognition that
the weather conditions could also be
severe and have a negative impact on
those sleeping outdoors in
loading wind snow and rain continuing to
provide accommodation even when severe
weather ends to allow time to arrange a
suitable move on plan I would welcome
the cabinet's view on the options is
outlined in the report but it is my view
that the humanitarian duty on the
council should weigh heavily in our
minds that we should recognize that by
protecting this vulnerable group we are
also reducing implications for other
public agencies such as health the
health service and GPS for these reasons
I will be supporting both options two
and three is described in the report and
if cabinet are minded to support my
proposal
I would like to make an additional
recommendation number four the offices
develop a new severe weather protocol
which describes the approach to
deploying protections to the known
receiver community in the event of all
severe weather conditions including snow
wind heat and rain is protocol to be
agreed by the portfolio holder of health
well-being housing and consultation with
the leader Thank You councillor Harris
council thank you Jim I'm happy that we
can support that when we first raised
this some time ago we asked that we
bring our protocol in line with
warwick's but as Chancellor Harris is
quite rightly pointed out the world has
moved on since then and I think we do
need to look at a wider a wider
recommendation just one point I have no
problem supporting what you're saying
except that we're already in freezing
weather so I would hope chairman that if
we look at a longer-term protocol that
we could agree possibly today for a
short-term protocol just to cover the
freezing nights of bad weather
because we are in winter and we don't
want to wait three four or five months
until next spring before changing the
way we operate Thank You Chancellor
Harris
councillor Harris right what was
confirming was how soon we could sign it
off if we wanted to go for the full long
term plan including it all probably if
it was agreed get it sorry in place in
the next two weeks
in that case looking at the
recommendations on page 99 and in
addition the recommendation really
apologized because it should pick this
up earlier would require a council
approval because you would be outside
the approved budget I'm since in the
sense for instance see here so if we
could possibly just amend the third
recommendation to say that the the
additional budget for 2018-19 is fund
from the forecast under spend for
2018-19 and then we can have deal with
any ongoing commitments as part of the
budget process so that then means it
doesn't need to go to council addition
to mr. Buckland's suggestion if we pick
up the recommendation for the counselor
Harris outlined and then do I have your
agreement cabinet great thank you
moving on brownfield land register which
in the absence of counsel append Burton
I will take and this is one of those
admirable papers where if I look on page
a hundred and seven the following
options are available to cabinets
option one to endorsed part one of the
updated brownfield land register for
publication option two to not endorse
Park wall of the updated brownfield Land
Register for publication however it is a
legal requirement to register be updated
at least annually this is what you call
a non decision so in the light of that
can I just
the recommendation on page 105 that the
updated brownfield Land Register part-1
been tossed for publication on the
council's website by 31st of December
2018 thereby complying with the legal
requirement do I have your agreement
members of cavity
thank you I did enjoy that resources and
property portfolio counselor organ item
13 merchant service charges Thank You
chairman the revenue budget monitoring
in September identified the rising cost
of merchant services relating to card
transactions there is the report has
taken place since then and the two main
reasons for the increase are for non
secure transactions firstly those that
currently go via councils contact center
because full payment card industry data
security standard which is abbreviated
to PCI DSS has not yet been implemented
and it's expected that this compliance
will take place by April 2019 the second
issue is a program update error that
resulted in 3d secure transactions far
the website being wrongly marked as
being non secure and this was corrected
immediately the error was discovered on
the 26th of September it is also
appropriate to review the costs of
merchant card services and following a
review a tender process has been
undertaken focus on banking was
commissioned to and take this review and
they have also undertaken a tender
process for the council using the crown
commercial services framework in
relation to merchant service charges
this has resulted in the council's
existing supplier being the most
economically advantageous tenderer with
the decrease in costs
subject to the supplier accepting the
framework the results of these three
actions being implemented our annual
savings are around forty six thousand
pounds however the budget for this year
is expected to be around 32 thousand as
the changes cannot be backdated and my
recommendation is that the actions taken
are noted and that the council does not
remove the ability to pay by a credit
card
Thank You councillor Morse in the change
around the secure non secure coding
which took place on the 23rd of February
yet we're told it was seven months later
September before it was picked up but
this was causing a significant
impairment to our costs that's my first
question why did it take so long and the
second question is how much has it cost
us we have a plethora of figures here I
think The Herald attributed 12,000
pounds to the cost and I wouldn't wish
to challenge the figures at all but it
seems to me that the actual cost though
it's offset by other savings the actual
cost of that would be 41,000 but if I'm
misunderstanding that and David's
telling me I am misunderstanding it put
it please correct here and tell me how
much this this problem actually cost us
mr. Buckland thank you yeah the issue in
relation to the script has costs of
council twelve thousand pounds of that
can't be recovered I agree with the
figure in the Heritage we gave it to
them so they published that figure that
that was just part of the contributory
factors there's been the three issues it
has been we await new that we're going
to incur non-secure charges in relation
to the contact center until we get the
full compliance on the PCI DSS and that
will happen as well we're getting there
the systems in place and that should
allow us to do so next year you should
to do with the internet payments was one
that should have been identified earlier
no it was only through the budget
monitoring that actually arose as a
particular issue so that is an issue for
us and then we need to improve on our
monitoring of the credit card invoices
which are coming through the other issue
was the increase in charges that were
imposed upon us by global payments we
are attempting to access the framework
through
the kraang commercial services we've
been deal dialog with Global Payments
about actually adopting that that
pricing framework at the moment so in my
opinion this whole issue opposed by the
way of monitoring something was off
track and now we've taken steps to
remedy it but I do accept the point that
we could have done better in monitoring
the invoices and that issue in relation
to the non secure charges for the
internet payments should have been
identified earlier Thank You councillor
Morse so with that if there are no
further comments can we make the
recommendation to note the actions that
have been taken to resolve the issue the
increased charges in relation to
merchant service charges agreed good
thank you
cabinet so capital budget monitoring
again council organ capital funding and
progress on expenditure is detailed in
appendix one section 106 funds held but
not yet committed are detailed in
appendix two and the recommendation is
that the position on capital expenditure
is received Thank You councillor Ross
Thank You chairman I notice on page 125
it states that refunded to McCarthy and
stolen a developer fifty seven and a
half thousand pounds for housing
presumably on the basis that we couldn't
find somewhere to spend it and their
self misunderstood it I found that
extremely disturbing and couldn't have
an explanation of why counselors were
not alerted in early stage that we were
in risk of having to repay this movie to
a developer
this is a historic one that has that was
dealt with in 1617 and was brought to
light in 1617 believe we did report it
in 2016-17 that there was a housing
development there was a virgin EMI for a
development in Sanborn unfortunately due
to the time that it takes for us to
collect the 106 from the developer that
the scheme that had been envisaged at
the time that the original 106 money was
collected it was no longer viable and
whilst we had tried to identify
alternate schemes and we had engaged
with the Sanborn Housing Trust
eventually there was just no options
that could comply with the word in the
original section 106 agreement and we
were obliged to we've done that III I
don't like to say to hand on her I'm
just pretty certain though that we did
report that through the cabinet Thank
You councillor Morse I assume that
actually this is a situation that
doesn't arise very often in general we
are very tight on monitoring section 106
I believe the word in in relation to the
106 is now more relaxed if we cannot
find an opportunity within the the
parish or neighboring parish then we can
apply it across the rest of the district
good okay so without that the capital
budget monitoring paper the
recommendation on page 117 acceptable to
cabinet the grade revenue your budget
monitoring again and forecasts a
favorable out turn of seventy-six
thousand five hundred and twenty seven
seven details of the main budget
variances are included within paragraph
3 of the report these are the budget
variances to date and the forecast out
turn is in paragraph four but the
biggest favorable variance talking about
out turn is ninety five thousand car
parking
new and the biggest unfavorable
variances with in housing with a
forecast overspend of 250,000 relating
mainly to additional expenditure on
homelessness I don't think we're
particularly surprised by either of
those two figures and as members are
aware the council was in the process of
purchasing further units of temporary
accommodation to help the homelessness
budget situation Thank You councillor
Morse chairman
I suspect council organ was surprised by
these figures because you may remember
that when we looked at the housing
budget overspend at the last cabinet
meeting and at the last overview and
scrutiny meeting and I questioned why at
the end of period 4 when we had an
overspend of a hundred and seventy-six
thousand we were forecasting and I
turned for the year of a hundred and
fifty thousand and I have expected those
papers with me chairman if anybody wants
to look at them so end a period for
actual spend 176 but we said we'd
recover 26 of that and bring it down to
150 for the year but I now see that it
shot up to 250 for the year another
hundred thousand chairman has appeared
since a vast revenue and Scootie in a
cabinet meeting I'm just wondering what
has changes so suddenly
mr. weeks can I help please yes and
there are two factors that chairman
councillor moss principally firstly that
the one that we touched on overview and
scrutiny committee on Wednesday morning
which was this discretionary payment to
avoid homelessness particularly when
private and social landlords are
bringing tendencies to an end that has
grown in common in practice over the
past two to three years and this year
particularly has ratcheted up an awful
lot as these landlords sadly
predominantly social landlords and have
become increasingly commercial in their
nature and the other aspect there the
biggest aspect has made an impact is
that the drawing down on the temporary
accommodation that we lease off orbit if
you recall we currently have about 25
properties that we supplement B&B use
from orbit released those we were
attempting to draw down an additional
ten it's taken forever to get them only
last week we drew down an additional
four so that whilst we're waiting for
those to come on stream it the burden on
the B&B persists and linked to that you
remember that the cabinet have agreed to
to go out and outright purchase some
additional properties irrespective of
the lease agreement with it and
conveyancing is a challenge at the
moment and no blast we've we've in the
process of purchasing two properties in
another three or four at the moment that
that is those that is holding us back as
well and all this time B&Bs is continued
to be used and as of today chairman we
sadly have a proper we have 24
households in been breakfast at the
moment
this increase of 100,000 pounds in the
expected outcome is adequate and can I
just say to him you seem to have shot
ourselves in the foot because you talk
about delays in conveyancing those
delays as I understand it they're
arising from delays at this council in
the land searches problem chairman can I
of course you can if you're asking me
now councillor Morse to predict
precisely what the end of your budget
will be if only I could it would be
great couldn't it what we're doing here
is giving you the best guess that we can
based on the circumstances right now or
certainly in this case probably about
two weeks ago that what it might look
like at the end of the year and I'm
afraid I can only do as good as that and
I am no way conflating two issues here
as you'll probably from familiar
conveyancing as a number of challenges
LAN charged inquiries is just one of
them and and cannot Konopka can you bear
with me one further for a moment
chairman because I suspected council
Morse was gonna raise this issue and
he's as he's consistent in this and and
rightly so chairman that the government
recognized that B&B and temper
accommodation and wrestling with
homelessness is a national challenge it
isn't a local one and it's widely
accepted that this kind of mosaic of
support services that used to once upon
a time stop people in some form of
crisis whether that's health financial
or some kind of physical health issue
falling into further decline and
becoming homeless that mosaic has kind
of crumbled over the years for a whole
host of different reasons and
consequently more and more people in our
presenting as homeless and this is
across the country now because the
current government were concerned about
it they've awarded over the past this
current financial next financial year as
a sum of money to each council their
homelessness discretionary homelessness
prevention grant and this money has been
awarded on the basis of relative
homelessness so the government have
looked at the stats that every council
has to supply on people in temporary
accomodation and also homelessness
presentations and they've worked out
using a formula how much money each
council will get so to put it crudely
chairman we have a league table of
homelessness that we can we can at least
look on if we want to now at the top of
the lead table you've got the silly
aisles where they receive absolutely no
money from their from the government
surprisingly if you go down that list
144 places you'll find Stratford now
bearing on the government and we were
awarded one hundred and forty one
thousand for this financial Yona 155 for
next year that the government are
releasing something in the region of 181
million pounds this year and 191 next
year so below as chairman there are 76
other authorities that are receiving far
more money than we are sadly the bottom
20 authorities sorry the bottom 33
authorities are receiving in excess of a
million and the bottom five councils are
receiving in excess of five million so I
would suggest that rather than dwelling
on that I think the the sadness that is
24 people in VMP at the moment we look
at it that he could be far worse and our
investment in in properties and low
investment in practice he's making a
bigger impact than perhaps other of that
or the council's and managing to achieve
right now thank you Jeff thank you
Robert may I just pick up on a point you
just mentioned there and please treyton
fire he got the wrong end of this
particular stick you're talking about
discretionary payments being made at the
coming to residents who have been made
homeless or whatever at the end of an
agreement with the social landlord I
think you mentioned that I just asked
the question you say this is now
increasing are we being taken for a ride
on this are we a soft-touch that we're
saying oh oh we'll just kick them out
here in the council takeover is this
something in your opinion or am I just
getting the wrong end of
mr. weeks German all I can tell you is
what's happening and how that's changing
in 1617 chairman we basically handed out
a grand total of thirteen thousand
pounds in order to sustain someone's
tenancy what happens is people will be
threatened with homelessness and at the
last minute they'll end up at court we
as a council work with the Citizens
Advice Bureau and have a court desk
worker who well the last minute try and
prevent someone from falling through
that net because if they do and they
present us homeless the social and
financial impact for their mandos far
greater than than partying with perhaps
two three thousand plans to clear their
areas for example as long as that's done
on the basis of a some kind of recovery
plan where they get counseling and
support to make sure that they're better
able to manage their finances and that
that has been a tool that has been
deployed widely on down country and
regularly because it makes make sense
but the 13,000 that we spent in 1617 has
grown during seventeen eighteen to
seventy one thousand and 1819 so far
were up to eighty one thousand gemin now
this is in my view a clear sign of a
commercial element creeping into the
social landlord landlord sector because
the feedback we have from the court desk
worker is that eighteen ninety percent
of the people that she tries to capture
and Fanning in fairness to hell and she
does a very good job of catching them
eighty ninety percent of them are social
landlord tenants and this is and
suddenly you'll be on wherever it was
raised at OSC on Wednesday of this week
where I asked the Chairman to consider
forming a task and finish group to
examine this very issue on this
particular issue it it's become really
apparent that the social landlords
largely one of our social landlords is
they are acting much much quicker and so
that's why the numbers appear to be
increasing and having 24 families in
made homeless isn't I would say 80% of
them maybe 90% of them are from the one
social landlord they're increasing
commercial 'ti whilst we understand that
means that we don't actually get to step
in and I've had personal experience with
the family where the bed and breakfast
accommodation that we provide as a
council is not anywhere near the place
that this person lives you can imagine
that they originally come from my ward
and the BMV zone in Stratford so the
discomfort to put it mildly that that
family are putting up with in order to
keep the children at school etc enormous
plus the costs plus we end up going to
local charities and getting them to
underpin so the whole situation around
people becoming homeless has got to be
looked at Thank You councillor Barker so
as chair of OSA you are setting up a
working group to look at this and I
assume it will report back to cabinet at
some stage in the future good and in
reality then we really do need to
monitor this area much more closely in
terms of both costs and the impacts as
outlined by mr. weeks because if this is
a situation is deteriorating then the
question is what do we do about it okay
with those comments in mind the
recommendations on page 129 are they
acceptable to cabinet a great thank you
so issues arising from over the in
scrutiny long cabinet work program to
note and stratford-upon-avon markets for
council more suddenly you wish to make a
comment
Thank You chairman on page 142 of their
agenda where it turns out our farmers
market now has three farmers I wonder at
what stage Jim and we can no longer
describe this as a farmers market it is
somewhat disturbing chairman and I
wonder what this council can do to bring
the farmers back mr. Webb yet
chairman quite happy to take that up
with the Markey contractor an estate
promotions I wasn't aware that it got as
low as that I must admit so that's
something that we can write through them
council was happy it delighted mr. Webb
can increase the number of farmers very
fair come on counselor brain and I think
you're absolutely right that there are
local producers there so thank you for
that with that cash management working
group to melt the minutes minutes noted
urgent business I've been informed of no
urgent business with that meeting closed
at 4:40